>> THAT MUST HAVE BEEN SOME
GREAT COLLEGE FRATERNITY PARTY
LAST NIGHT. I CAN'T REMEMBER A
THING. WAIT! HOW DID I GET HOME?
AND WHY DO MY PARTS HURT?
>> HOLD IT RIGHT THERE.
THE REASON YOU CAN'T REMEMBER
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU LAST NIGHT
IS BECAUSE SOMEBODY GAVE YOU
ROOFIES.
>> ARE YOU SAYING I GOT RAPED
LAST NIGHT?
>> YES. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I'M
SAYING. YOU GOT RAPED.
BUT IT'S LIKE THE SAYING GOES:
RAPE ME ONCE, SHAME ON YOU.
RAPE ME TWICE...
Both: SHAME ON ME!
>> NEXT TIME, TRY WEARING
GENUINE POLICE TEK 2000 RAPE
SHIELD UNDERGARMENTS. CANNOT BE
OPENED WITHOUT THEIR CODED
INFRARED CONTROLLER.
[BEEP, BEEP]
>> WOW, THOSE LOOK WELL-MADE.
>> TRUST ME...ONCE YOU'VE BEEN
NOT RAPED TWICE, POLICE TEK RAPE
SHIELD UNDERGARMENTS HAVE PAID
FOR THEMSELVES.
SO REMEMBER...YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE A SUPER MODEL TO GET RAPED.
>> POLICE TEK 2000 RAPE SHIELD
UNDERGARMENTS SOUND JUST...SOUND
LIKE JUST THE TICKET.
Both: THE TICKET TO RAPE SAFETY.
[BEEP, BEEP]